the biggest mistake that entrepreneurs
will make is that they then look at the
greener grass on the other side of the
fence and say man I shouldn't be doing
flipping I should be doing crypto
trading or whatever they have uninformed
optimism so they go into it being like
this is going to be amazing 6 months in
and they're like I now have informed
pessimism and then they go into the
valley of Despair and that's usually
where they're at it you're three-ish I
remember the things that that got me
into this those things are true but
there are these other things that you
also have to account for and then you
get to the fifth step which is just like
Mastery achievement of the goal whatever
it is and so most people just do step
one two three over and over again the
uninformed optimism informed pessimism
value of Despair switch a lot of people
start over when they really just need to
push further